you collaborated with prince i remember
i was in london and i got a call and
they're like
um the artist is on the phone which is
so bizarre it was the artist and he was
did you know who they were talking about
i did i thought they were talking about
me
but i was in shock
he says i have a song that i want you to
be on and kind of it was kind of like a
deal like in exchange i'll help you with
one of your songs and now are you
calling him the artist
at that point um i don't know what i did
i think i just
didn't call him anything was it weird
could prince is such a genius and all of
that i mean isn't it it's just kind of
intimidating it was super scary and
intimidating and how's the whole thing
go down i'm curious here you are a
songwriter you're going to you're going
to collect you have a song and i had the
song i sent it i sent him the demo of
what we had started called waiting room
and when i got off the plane in
minneapolis we're going through the
airport his his bodyguard was there and
he had this phone he's like the artist
wants to speak to you again i was like
okay so he puts me on the cell phone and
he goes i had to rewrite the song and i
was like okay
he's like but i think you're going to
like it and so we get to the studio and
he's standing there paisley park and
he's there and he's super sweet and like
is there anything
is there an instant sort of chemistry in
the sense that you both speak the same
language musically no he's on a whole
nother planet level like he barely talks
right i mean that night before
i forgot that the night we came in he
did like a five-hour concert in his like
home concert like yeah he was like a
workaholic yeah he he really loved music
yeah and so and then you stand there
with him and he plays for you the new
version of yourself yeah and it was the
one that you hear on the rock steady
route which almost sounds like the
batman soundtrack it was that time
period don't you love the batman
soundtrack don't you think that's like
one of his best good i mean i love i
love under the cherry moon i love all of
his stuff how long was the session i
mean how long do you felt like we were
there a couple days oh really yeah and
it's like non-stop i went in the booth
and i did not come out for like eight
hours i'd like can i get a water like it
was like and he would be like sitting at
the desk and he just literally one
like harmony after another he would just
feed it to me and i would have to like
spit it back out and i was it was scared
i was so scared because i'm not even
that good of a singer do you know what
i'm saying like
i i i don't agree with that i think your
songs are hard to sing i i don't think
those are easy but i'm saying
technically as a singer i'm like i kind
of have my style or whatever but it's
not like i have a big range or you know
what i mean i i can sing and tune and i
can hear notes but but he's like a i
mean he's just like a genius you know
what i'm saying he's and he's he's like
oh i haven't done these kind of um these
kind of like harmonies since like wendy
and lisa and i'm just sitting there
going is this happening to me right now
this is incredible